dans de nombreux villages d'alsace du
nord il n'ya qu'un seul péché et il est
bien souvent protestants comme tous les
dimanches matin monsieur le pasteur
accueille ses paroissiens avant le culte
âgé d'à peine trente trois au lion
gerber a endossé la fonction pastorale
il ya sept ans avec bonheur car ici les
fidèles sont au rendez vous il ya une
forte présence protestante et une
histoire protestante aussi pour quelques
uns servent à ces pratiques hier assez
suivie d une heure de prière et de
prêches ou le sourire espiègle de la
fille du pasteur vient balayer la pseudo
l'austérité des protestants et
d'ailleurs à la sortie du put cela se
passe comme ça à la maison mais monsieur
le bassin celui de madeleine car maman
est aussi allaster épuisé ils incarnent
tous deux une nouvelle génération de
près l'application c'est une chose de ce
qui arrive qu'on peut pas vraiment
expliquer qui tout à fait personnel
et qui n'est pas forcément spectacle et
revenir moi j'ai pas une vision coûts
par exemple derrière un peeling notre
navale à claudel mais je pense c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut vraiment
laisser le temps de mûrir
isabelle j'avais n'a pas de paroisses
mais dirige avec énergie un mouvement de
jeunesse luc herzog
on a effectivement qu'ils se rendent
compte que il ya des outils dans la foi
qui nous permet vraiment de de tenir
debout dans la vie et d'avoir une
espérance pour isabelle et lilian bret
être pasteur c'est bien le métier le
plus accueillant du monde